[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouvel envie de
lecture d'attali wolf bonjour franchir
patrice je suis que vous êtes ravi parce
que vous êtes une grande voyageuse une
grande exploratrice veut déjà allé
jusqu'à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin exactement le
que la voiture n'a pas de secrets pour
vous sans limite avec le rer
vous serez vous nous connaissez manet et
chez trion worlds et narcejac marx
engels edouard philippe et gilles boyer
bien maintenant voici faille et sans
clément bonjour bonjour catherine faille
bonjour marine santé montrent vous êtes
vous êtes du journaliste tout les deux
vous êtes spécialiste dans les voyages
dans les découvertes de dd terre un peu
inconnu
j'ai d'ailleurs rencontré je crois au
qatar et on a la pression d'ailleurs qu
entre vous une sorte de coup de foudre
professionnel et et amicale et nous est
ici parce que vous publiez un livre
écrit à quatre mains qui s'appelle
l'année des deux dames qui publie aux
éditions pol scène récit de voyage pour
lesquelles vous avez d'ailleurs déjà
obtenu le prix jules verne et vous
figurer parmi les sept finalistes du
prix joseph kessel
alors on va parler de ce livre un livre
qui nous fait du bien parce que comme on
le disait basse étant de confinement à
ça nous permet d'ouvrir les portes les
fenêtres
et puisque grâce à lui nous allons
voyager pas n'importe où dans ce pays
assez méconnu qu'est la mauritanie alors
tout part en réalité pour vous d'une
visite chez un bouquiniste lors de
laquelle vous tombez sur un livre qui
est signée de odette depuis godault et
de mars marion sénonais ce de quoi
s'agit-il
qui veut répondre elle a donc en fait
donc nous quand nous sommes rentrés du
qatar avec marine nous souhaitions
partir repartir ensemble mais avec un
projet comment et c'est en marchant sur
les quais de seine que nous sommes
tombés sur ce livre pieds nus à travers
la mauritanie de dettes du puigaudeau et
de marion senonnes chez un bouquiniste
la couverture nous attirer et puis le
fait que ce livre se passe en mauritanie
également puisque c'est un pays qui
nous était méconnu et qui est passé
méconnu en général et c'est comme ça que
l'aventuré a démarré puisque nous avons
acheté ce livre et en découvrant que
deux femmes étaient partis dans les
années 30 halle aventure nous nous
sommes dit eh bien notre tour nous
allons aller sur leurs traces leur
redonner une voix parce qu'elle était
tombée dans l'oubli et maître nous
mettre nous mêmes à l'épreuve de ce
voyage
d'ailleurs on voit bien que l'une des
deux femmes ressemble étrangement à
l'une d'entre vous mais c'est catherine
feuille alors la première réflexion
qu'on se fait quand on commence votre
livre c'est une réflexion sur le courage
on se dit mais comment il y à 90 ans et
ses deux femmes que vous venez d'évoquer
l'une a été styliste l'autre modélistes
et qui sont devenues elles aussi
journaliste beaucoup de east comment est
ce qu'elle décide de se jeter dans
l'inconnu gagne par davanture chez elle
ça c'est indéniable mais est ce qu'il
n'ya pas aussi part d'inconscience
peut-être une part d'inconscience
c'est vrai que les raisons de leur
départ ne sont pas très claires à
l'envers de certains vous aventuriers
qui partent avec un but pour l on a eu
on a mis du temps à comprendre un peu
quelles étaient leurs requêtes
alors il ya plusieurs choses qui entrent
en compte elle essaie t elle avait
beaucoup de mal à exercer leur
profession sans pour eux d'être sa
profession de journaliste en tant que
femme à paris elle en parle beaucoup
dans ses livres dans ses carnets la
difficulté de devoir s'habille en homme
constamment pour être pour être acceptée
il ya aussi l
elle rêve d'embarquer avec charcot sur
une grande expédition et on lui refuse
l'accès parce que c'est une femme encore
donc il ya quand même chez odette ce
désir de voyage qui est nourri depuis
depuis de nombreuses années et c'est
finalement sa rencontre avec marion qui
va être l'élément déclencheur puisque
quand elles partent elles ne se
connaissent que depuis un an
donc on se dit partir comme ça justement
avoir autant de courage pour pour partir
sur dans une terre qui était même pas
pacifié encore à l'époque avec une
personne qu'on connaît à peine parce que
non c'est quand même lourd
il y avait aussi du courage dans ce sens
là alors notez l'hiver raisons la
première réflexion c'est le courage de
de vos héroïnes si je peux dire mais la
deuxième réflexion qu'on se fait
immédiatement
c'est votre courage à vous parce que là
il ya le conflit entre le maroc et la
mauritanie
il ya évidemment la montée de
l'islamisme
il ya ce no man's land qu'il faut
traverser pour arriver en mauritanie
justement qui est qui est un véritable
coupe-gorge s'inquiète une zone de tous
les dangers
il ya des prises d'otages il ya eu des
assassinats c'est là qu'on se dit que
peut-être des vrais inconsciente c'est
pas c'est pas d'être et mario ccc vous
est ce que est ce que vous vous n'en
parlez pas beaucoup parce que vous êtes
tellement vous êtes obsédé derrière pas
s'être autres d'être sur la trace de
deux de ces deux femmes est ce que vous
avez eu peur
par moments sincèrement non je pense que
nous étions portés par notre part ce
désir cette quête
peut-être une fois lorsque nous étions
vent à l'est du pays où on le raconte
d'ailleurs dans le livre
7 cette voiture est arrivée ce cas 4
avec des hommes armés là oui il ya eu
l'espace d'un instant cette peur qu
est-ce que c'est est ce qu'il s'agit de
terroristes ou de brigands notre guide
et notre chauffeur tout de suite sont
intervenus sont allé leur parler
on ne sait pas vraiment ce qu'il s'est
dit ce qui s'est passé et à ce moment là
d'ailleurs et on le dit dans le livre a
toujours
que nous avons pris la décision de ne
pas continuer dans cette direction là et
de mettre un peu plus prudent il ya une
scène très fortes aussi que vous
racontez il faut monter sur un bateau il
est haut ça n'est pas facile personne ne
vous aide et ont fini par vous dire
pourquoi
oui alors c'est vrai qu'il ya des
moments comme ça en plus c'est le moment
dont vous parlez c'était vraiment tout
au début les premiers jours de notre
aventure et il y avait on devait monter
à ont été embarqués et ce bateau était
un peu inaccessible c'était un bateau de
pêcheurs et et à la force des bras on
n'arrivait pas à se hisser en plus vous
avez pas notre gabarit mais mais moi je
mesure 1 m 53 donc c'est pas évident et
en fait on était démuni on était là mais
aidez nous s'il vous plaît avant de se
rendre compte évidemment qu'on était
entourée d'hommes et que des hommes
n'allaient pas prendre par les anges qui
ne sont payées que voilà il ya eu des
petits au début de notre pays
particulièrement
on a eu des petits manquements en fait
part par manque d'habitude on a on as
pas qu'on a oublié les les traditions et
les règles locales mais mais ça nous est
pas apparu évident et ça nous a causé
avec quelques petits désagréments
parfois dire les populations comment
elle vous regarde est justement alors
elle nous regardaient avec beaucoup de
curiosité je pense et d'interrogations
c'était on a eu plusieurs fois le
discours mais qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que vous venez faire et si j'avais des
voitures chez vous et vous traversez le
dr sur des chameaux
vous avez la peau blanche qui est en
mauritanie nom symbole de beauté et vous
venez la noircir sous notre soleil donc
il y avait un peu d'incompréhension
m'aimait beaucoup de bienveillance
toujours quand même alors que je
souhaitais intéressant ce qui était
intéressant par ailleurs c'était
justement la leur leurs étonnements de
nous voir là mais aussi ça laisse à les
conforter dans l'idée que en aucun cas
ils voudraient venir chez nous et
dans nos pays qu'est ce que nous venons
chercher chez eux
est ce que nous n'avons pas chez nous
ceux du monde il ya des inscriptions on
veut parler aussi des gens que vous
rencontrez
ils les descriptions magnifique de des
lieux alors j'ai appris par exemple il y
avait un banc d'arguin a en mauritanie
moi je préside et à côté d'arcachon
pas du tout et j'aurais dû le savoir
parce que c'est là qu'a eu le le drame
de durable enfin de la méduse la méduse
qui a échoué puis de le radeau de la
méduse de géricault après un ca
c'est ça c'est très intéressant
il a effectivement deux barrettes de
bandar ya dans le monde
à l'entrée du bassin d'arcachon et
l'autre en mauritanie
et c'est donc celui du de mauritanie
c'est du mont lacq à l'élu de beuvrages
de la frégate de ensuite devenu le
radeau de la méduse et c'est la
ressemblance est assez étonnante alors
en mauritanie le bond est dix fois plus
grandes icônes 10 fois plus vaste mais
je étaient toutes originaires de la
région du sud ouest de la france et
connaissant bien le banc d'arguin à
l'entrée du bassin d'arcachon il été
surprises par la ressemblance non
seulement du banc de sable mais
également de la bête qui ressemble un
petit peu au bassin d'arcachon et ses
escargots britannia qui a donné le nom
du banc d'arguin français
alors revenons à l'essentiel à ces deux
femmes et vous finissez on rappelle alan
voyage c'est 1938 vous finissez sur un
homme qui les a connus ceux qui liront
le livret on les y encourage
mais bon qu'à la fin de votre récit vous
vous interrogez sur leurs motivations
alors est-ce qu'ils sont aussi pur ces
deux femmes que vous les aviez imaginé
en tout cas on a l'impression vous nous
et c'est un doute
catherine je sais pas si tu veux prendre
la parole ou alors le je sais pas s'il
est question de pureté en revanche c'est
vrai qu'on est parti avec une image
d'elles qui était peu qu'on idéalise est
en tout cas on a découvert au fil de nos
lectures et au fil des rencontres aussi
que finalement il y avait peut-être
c'était peut-être pas aussi aussi
agréable qu'on voulait le penser elles
ont un peu retourné leur veste sur
certains sujets notamment le
colonialisme d' esclavage donc se
déroule un peu parfaites elles sont
devenus des femmes plus je pas dire plus
banal mais elle était en tout cas on a
décédée chez elle des aspérités en fait
qui sont propres à l'être humain mais
mais ont elles sont tombées plus tôt
dans l'anti héroïne qu'on n'avait pas
imaginé
donc ça oui et revenons à la religion
alors odette était était assez fasciné
par l'islam elle truc c'est une religion
qui va qui va bien aux lieux et aux
hommes d'ailleurs qu'ils habitent
il faut dire vous le racontez d'ailleurs
que c'est une époque on nous parle
volontiers drass avril avait un petit
peu a évoqué à l'instant et d'ailleurs
et des passages du livre qu'on n'oserait
plus écrire aujourd'hui quel est votre
sentiment à vous sur cette société mais
également sur le poids de la religion de
d'abord en ce qui concerne odette et
marion je pense que même si
effectivement on est parent on n'était
pas d'accord marine et moi même sur un
certain nombre de choses pour
recontextualiser on est dans les années
30 on est vraiment à une autre époque
c'est il peut toujours faire attention
un siècle plus tard au regard qu'on peut
porter sur le la pensée le comportement
même si nous on a notre avis ce que le
poids de l'islam sur la société
mauritanienne
la religion est très présente sam est
très différent en ville
et dans le désert ou dans les campagnes
entre guillemets moi je ne le vois pas
comme un poids je le vois comme une
culture comme une façon de vivre
qu'en penses-tu marine mais c'est
exactement ça c'est tellement inscrits
ça fait tellement partie 2 qui vivent
leur islam comme ils l'entendent mais ça
n'a jamais été
on n'a jamais par exemple je prends un
exemple qui nous est arrivé dans
d'autres pays on ne nous a jamais
interdit l'accès à une mosquée en
mauritanie
les petites choses comme ça il y aurait
peu de caisse qui ont malheureusement le
temps qui nous est imparti sait que
c'est fini pratiquement donc j'avais
plein de questions vous posez sur la
façon d'ailleurs de vous avez écrite
parce que c'est très amusant parce que
comme marine
on sent qu'il ya des des chapitres que
vous écrivez vous parlez de catherine
quand catherine écrit elle parle de vos
réactions
j'ai juste alors pour conclure une
dernière question il ya évidemment plein
de gens qui vont être attirés par ce par
ce voyage que vous avez fait vous de le
recommander d'aller en mauritanie ou
faut faire gaffe quand même moi j'ai de
moi je moi absolument je dis qu'on peut
aller en mauritanie sans aucun problème
maintenant il faut pas avoir envie d'un
hôtel luxueux où dormir confortablement
ou voilà c'est un petit peu ça mais on
peut y aller et est évidemment et si on
va sur les traces de ces deux femmes
dans que vous retracer dans l'année des
deux dames sécher paulson et évidemment
je pense qu'il va pouvoir beaucoup trop
tôt aussi d'illustration je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui vont être
fasciné et par ce livre est pas votre
récit merci infiniment merci à vous pour
leurs crédits pour vous merci merci
beaucoup
on
[Musique]